Oh, hello there, I'm Gav.
Oh, hello, I'm Dan.
Oh, hello.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
We're sat down.
Take a seat yourself, if you want.
No need to stand.
Why would they be stood
there on the computer?
Like, as soon as they're
like, oh, Slow Mo Guys video.
Just stand up to watch this.
Few months ago, we were very kindly given
this car by Traxxas.
It goes 100 miles an hour.
Beast.
We used it 'cause it was the fastest car
I could find on the internet,
and we had a problem
when we were filming it
in that the audio was
too good, crystal clear,
sort of so good that it
hurt your ears to listen to.
Often the case on a Slow Mo Guys video.
Often the case.
Here's an example of it.
See what I mean?
Yeah, very clear.
Sounds very clear.
So what we're gonna do is
make a new intro for you
that is worse sounding.
First thing we thought we'd
do is test out the speed
by driving it at myself
at 100 miles an hour.
I thought, wouldn't it be cool
if you could jump over a
100 mile an hour object
coming straight at your own legs?
I was like, yeah.
So, wait, I have to drive
it at myself and jump?
And then you're like, also do a 180,
so I had to jump,
turn in the air,
still controlling the
car, at 100 miles an hour.
Woo.
Was that scary?
It's pretty weird.
Next, we decided, what
would a crash look like?
Little off-road spill,
so Dan drove the car from the flat tarmac
onto the grass, and I
tracked it in high speed.
This is what it looked like.
Oh.
Serious James Bond flips there.
It looked pretty cool.
Yeah, kicked up the grass,
flying through the air.
I've done it in real
life, and let me tell you,
it's better to watch it when
it's a remote control car,
not you in the car.
Fiddling with the radio, weren't you?
Yeah, I told people there was an animal
and I swerved to avoid it,
but I was literally just
playing with the radio,
not paying attention,
and I span it backwards into a bush.
Well done there.
Yep, good work.
Next up, we thought it'd be a good idea
to pour a lump of flour on the road
and have it drive either
over it or through it.
Either way, the particles
of flour should look cool.
Okay, so, to help show
the speed of this car,
I'm gonna plunk down an
entire bag of flour here
and watch it get obliterated in slow mo.
Oh.
We were actually mainly out there
filming the flamethrower video,
of which all of the
audio is fine, somehow.
The wind must've kicked up
while we were doing this one,
so you suited up again,
and we drove the car through the flames.
So, at this point,
we haven't broken this thing yet, somehow,
so I felt like the finale was clear.
Just get another one.
Get a second one of these bad boys.
This one's all see-through, obviously,
so we can see the individual bits
when it crashes into this one.
We went for a head-on collision.
Oh.
Aw, that wheel is wedged up there.
Is it in the car?
Yeah, it's, like, shoved up inside.
My beauty.
So when we were filming that, I thought,
little bit wasteful, what we did there.
Sort of very high performance
remote control cars,
definitely for enthusiasts.
Yeah.
But I've gotta say, whenever
I see a remote control car,
I always think, what would it look like
if two slammed into each other?
I know that people that
want one of these cars
and use these cars would be like,
oh, I really want to crash one into it,
but I just can't do it, 'cause it's mine.
It's my piece of kit.
It would be,
I really want to crash one.
I don't want to crash mine.
Yeah, yeah.
We've done it for you in slow motion.
Yeah, so it is wasteful,
but now you don't have to experiment
and damage your own goods,
if you were thinking of it.
Probably weren't, but.
Worth it. Worth it.
I don't know, I'm always
fascinated by destruction.
A big, wet thanks to Traxxas
for giving us two free cars,
and then repairing them for us.
They put them into the GTA garage,
and moved it back out,
and that's all it...
Straight in and out.
Very much appreciate it
for the use of this video,
and hopefully, you got some
enjoyment out of it too.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter,
buy some smerch, and...
Second channel?
So this is second channel too.
Yep.